*Everyone already laughing*
Mark: Are you okay?
Bob: I think it's just funny how much you hated that experience.
*Mark laughs*
Mark: Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to The Amazing Frog.
Mark: herp
Mark: Uhhhh
Mark: Hi
Mark: Uhh this is The Amazing Frog.
Mark: We are the amazing frogs!
Wade: *giggles*
Mark: Uhhh, I'm top right!
Bob: I'm the big one.
Mark: Yeah...
Mark:  Uhh I'm just dragging myself.. We don't knoooow what this game's about... Oh!
Mark: Arcades!  What the heck!?!
Wade: Nice!
Mark: Oh no.
Mark: Oh no... I don't want this.
Mark: Ok that's... that's not what we are looking for.
Wade: Ohp! (giggles)
Bob: Hey buddy!
Mark: where the fuck do we.. Guys STOP!!
Bob: Oh god!
Mark: How the fuck do we start?
Wade: How you get on this game?
Bob: *laughing*
Wade: Bob we're playing together
Bob: Wade and I are just playing this whole other game. (Laughs) We don't even know what's going...
Everyone: Whoa!
Bob: Oh! Hey...
Mark: Finally! We found the way to go I think?.      Wade:Oh                                                                        Mark:Okay
Mark: So we've never played The Amazing Frog before. None of us. None of one of us. (good englishing mark)
Bob & Wade: Nooo *laughing*
Bob: (laughing) Not at all.
Mark: I don't have any idea what you're supposed to do-
Mark: -why you're supposed to do it. Oh god
Bob: Ok?
Mark: The fuck is this?
Mark: Oh.
Bob: (Laughs hysterically)
Mark: Stop!
*More laughter*
Mark: STOP HITTING ME! STOP!!!!!
Bob: Weeee!
Mark: Oh my god.
Bob: Faaaaaaaaaa
Bob and Wade: Faaaaaaaaaaaaa! *Bob giggles*
Mark: Okaay...
Mark: I'm gonna... Why is this... Oh it's so laggy!
Wade: I don't...
Wade: I don't know.
Mark: Ohhh nooo!
Mark: This was a mistake--Okay, I'm in a cannon.
Mark: Here we go!
Wade: (laughs)
Bob: Wait, I got this thing, what does this do? *explodes*
Mark blandly says "Ow."
Bob: Oh there's a cannon?!
Wade: WWOOAAHHH!
Mark: yeah there's a cannon
Bob: Oh, sick!
Mark: Okay?...
Mark: What the fucking fuck?
Wade: Where- Where'd you go?
Bob: AAWWW BABY
Bob: Wassup!
Mark: Oh... Okay...
Bob: What's up blue motherfucker?
Wade: AAAAAAHHHHHH!!!!!!
Bob: OHMYGODDD!!!!
Mark: hang on
Bob: Haaaaaa
Bob: Awww, jeez.
Wade: (laughs)
Bob: These are some floppy frogs we got here.
Mark: This is some weird bullshit.
Mark: Is there an objective to this or...
Bob: Is this Goat Simulator with frogs and multiplayer?
Mark: I think... I think yes.
Wade: *laughing*
Bob: *laughs* You go on your back, you go spread eagle
Wade: I can't get out!
Bob: Can we get in cars??
Mark: I don't think so. I blew up a car when I hit it with the cannon.
Bob: (gasps) I'm in the back of a car!
Wade: YEAH!!
Mark: How, how did you aim?
Bob: I'm in the back of a car!!
Wade: (groans)
Wade: How'd you get back to the cannon?
Mark: I walked? You lazy sack of crap.
Bob: (gasps) Wade, do you want to come ride in my car?
Wade: Yeah, I'm going to shoot my way right there.
Bob: Is that an NPC just endlessly running into a wall? (laughs)
Mark: I'm going to present this option.
Fucking bail on this game.
Bob: (giggles)
Mark: It's hard to watch, it's hard to play.
Bob: (continues giggling).
Mark: No one's going to watch this.
Bob: Wait, but look at this guy
Mark: Ohhh jesus...
Bob & Wade: *laughing*
Wade: I'm having fun guys.
Bob: Oh God!
Wade: my hand is stuck in the... *laughing*
Wade: My hand is stuck in the car *laughing* (Mark's face of disapproval) Bob: if you just spam jump, you can walk around like this
Wade: My hand is stuck in the car, Bob
Wade and Bob: *laughing*
Wade: Who's that?? ... Help me!
Wade: Please! Oh...
Bob: *laughing*
*one of the frogs farts*
*Laughing*
Bob: Oh I can set you up! Look, I'll help you up, friend. Wade: Oh, thank you
Bob: Come here friend.
Wade: Thanks.
Bob: Come, come, come here!
Mark: Wait, why, what happened?
Wade: What? Who's gone?
Bob: (gasps)
Mark: OOOHHH
Mark: How'd you do that??
Wade: Am I dead?
Bob: Did I kill you??
Wade: You killed me!
Bob: (gasps)
Mark: How- how do you do that?
Wade: I'm back.
Bob: Are we supposed to kill each other?
Mark: How do you do that?
Bob: Oh my god.
All: WOAH
Wade: Woah, what happened to me there?
Bob: Look now I'm mounting- oh- ohh- Nevermind.
All:  *groans* *whines*
Wade: Whoaa
Mark: (yells) Ah....
Bob: Oh my god what happened to you? *laughs*
Mark: (continues yelling)
Bob and Wade: (continue laughing)
Mark: I don't feeeel good
Bob and Wade: *laughing*
Mark: Mothah!
Wade: I can't get up!
Mark: Mothah!!
Bob: I can't get off Wade!
Mark: Mothah!
Bob & Wade: *laughter*
Mark: Oh! Don't tell fathah!
Bob: Oh! I got him. I got him.
Wade: Good, good work.
Mark: Oh no...
Mark: Alright now get-
Bob: Look, now I'm crotch, crotch-banging you all over the place.
Mark: okay... (groans)
Wade: Good work. Keep it up!
Mark: Brothah! brothah!
Bob: What the fuck is fucking happening?
Mark: Help me, brothah...
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: Ohh.
Mark: Help me, brothah.
Bob: Why are you shaped like a huge dick?
All: OH!
Bob: Woah. woah. Woah! Hey easy.
Bob: Woah.
Mark: Woah.
Wade: Come here.
Bob: Wait, I want to ride the trampoline with Mark. Set us on the trampoline.
Wade: Uh...
Mark: This game is great
Bob: This game is-
Wade: AH!
Bob: See ya!
Wade: But-
Bob: Alright, you know what, Mark? you-
Wade: Ohh
Mark: Alright.
Bob: You can exist again.
Mark: Well... Alright, thank you
Mark: Incoming, incoming! Hweyy!!
Bob: Holy shit.
Mark: Oh boy.
Mark: Alright, I'm going for the-
Bob: You're so high.
Mark: The mythical third bounce.
Bob: There's a little boy on the ground. Who's this?
Mark: *yells* Ah!
Bob: It's a...
Bob: Wait, Wade.
Wade: That's my crown! Where is he?
Bob: What, hey.
Wade: Where's that little piece of...
Bob: Woah, he's over here now.
Wade: I'm gonna get him.
Mark: *yells* Incoming!
Wade: Hey, oh God!
Bob: Hey buddy.
Wade: Come here.
Bob: What the...
Wade: WOAH
Bob: *gasps* his crown came off! his crown
Mark: His crown!
Wade: I need that!
Bob: crown! crown!
Wade: *grunting*
Bob: Oh shit, give me the fucking crown.
Wade: No! no- okay
Mark: Give me the fucking crown
Bob: Come here bitch! Come here bitch.
Wade: No no, you're never going to catch me. Mister, take this crown. Hide it!
Wade: Hi- hi- hide it. oh
Mark and Bob: Ah
Bob: Got you bitch  Mark: Ah, that's mine
Mark: Aw Yeeeeehhh!
Mark: Oh fuck!
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: Heeey
Mark: They'll never catch me now
Bob: Oh, I think we'll catch you *laughter*
Mark: Fuck. fuck aw fuck.
Mark: fuck. There we go! That's correct.
Bob: Come here bitch.
Mark: No.
Mark: Mart-eh-part (idk either)
Wade: Is that my crown?
Bob: is that my fucking crown?
Mark: Fucking-
Bob: You got my fucking crown over there?
Mark: Fuckin'- I can't fucking go the right way.
Mark: There we go.
Bob: You got my fucking crown over there?
Wade: Yeah, is that my crown?
Mark: You want a fucking crown?
Mark: Aah!
Bob: Oh yes!
Everyone: *Grunting*
Mark: Fuck it
Bob: Yes!
Mark: Fuck you.
Bob: OH MY GOD OH NO!
Mark and Wade: *laughing*
Mark: The crown's power was too much!
Bob: OH GOD
Bob: Oh no oh no! It's getting worse!
Mark: Stop, God!
Mark: Stop!
Bob: I need to get out of here!
Mark: I'll help you!
Wade: Oh God!
Bob: Alright, I'm better, i'm better, I'm better.
Bob: *Laughing* Ah, I gotchya bitch!
Mark and Wade: laughing
Wade: No!
Mark: My crown!
Wade: Get him! After that frog!
Bob: get Mark!
Bob: Come here, motherfucker!
Wade: After that frog!
Bob: Oh God, our bodies were tangled in the mysterious dance of love.(do you say that a lot Bob?)
Wade: laughing
Mark: Ah, fuck you!
Mark: *yelling and screaming*
Bob & Wade: *laughing*
Mark: *yelling*
Bob and Wade: *Laughing*
Bob: Yay, got the crown, yay!
Wade: laughing
Mark: *yelling*
Wade: Bob!
Bob and Wade: *laughing*
Mark: *yelling*
Wade: Ohh no!
Mark: Okay, we're back we're back we're back.
Bob: wait, what if I do this?
Bob: ehh.. up.. Seeya!
Bob: I'm in my impenetrable king car now, bitches.
Bob: Drive me around.
Mark: Okay.
Bob: Take me to church
Mark: it won't go
Bob: yeah, it doesn't drive
Wade: *Laughing*
Mark: Alrighty then.
Wade: well!
Bob: we're just in the car.
Bob: hey, let's pretend to drive
Bob: Why don't you start the car, Mark?
Mark: *Makes chuffing car noises for ignition*
Mark: It says Jack Septic.
Wade: I. Bob: Wow.
Bob: Let's get the fuck outta this car.
Mark: Yeah, fuck this car, Jesus. (HOW DARE THEY DISRESPECT JACK?!)
Bob: let's uh, let's go somewhere else.
Wade: AH! oof.
Bob: Ugh, Frog Milk- Frog Milk Coffee
Bob: ..alright
Wade: better stop by
Bob: better at least say hello
Bob: hello!
Mark: Op- here we go
Bob: Nope- I'm just gonna- if I could-
Bob: If I could have my crown back
Bob: If I could- please-
Wade: It's not- it's- never your crown-
Bob: If I could get my-
Bob: Whoaaa
Bob: I'm gonna get a rockstar hot coffee
Bob: I don't have enough rewards points to get this
Bob: *reads text on screen*
Mark: Hey! I'm drivin' it!
Wade: Are you?!
Mark: I'm drivin' it!
Wade: How'd you learn to drive?!
Mark: Get in!!
Bob: Okay so I- I currently
Wade: I'm coming
Mark: Get in!
Bob: I currently have the objective to destroy booh... booh--
Wade: *chokes*
Bob: Wa-wa-wait
Mark: Get in!
Bob: hehuuh!
Mark: Nice
Bobs: Hoohh two points!
Wade: I'm comin' back
Mark: I'm gonna scoop up- I'm gonna scoop up
Bob: oh no! If I stand up, I get out- hang on
Bob: ah ugh ugh eh eeh eh
Wade: Man-
Bob: Whooaa
Mark: Alrriiight
Wade: Yeah
Bob: Alright!
Mark: Where would you like to go?
Wade: Uh, let's go.. I dunno
Wade: Can we use the ramps?
Mark: gonna try to get one more person!
Wade: *laughs*
Mark: I'm here!
All: Ohhhhh
Wade: oh! Oh no!
Mark: Sorry!
Bob: yeah-
Bob: WHOA
Mark: Bumpy ride!
Bob: hang on- hang on!
Wade: Oooohh
Mark: Sorry- Sorry
Wade: *laughs*
Bob: Let me back in!
Mark: Sorry
Wade: Bye Bob
Mark: Who's farting?
Bob: I'm farting for some reason
Bob: There I am- comin' i'm comin;
Bob: IIIII'm comin, there we go
Mark: Ya in? alright
Mark: Where shall I-
Bob: Let's go- let's go hit that sick ramp
Bob: that was over by the- the trampoline
Wade: Yeahh
Mark: on target
Wade: Yeah- Yeah! Ooohh *laughs*
Mark: ooohkay
Bob: Hey! that-
Wade: Welp
Mark: That was exciting
Bob: that's almost not hilarious at all
Bob: I wanna drive the purple car, fuckin- fuck this
Bob: Aw i'm in the back, fuck that
Mark: Ow
Bob: Hey *laughs* how's it going
Wade: I'm in
Mark: I'm in
Bob: Any second now. Are you saying you have to hold 'R'?
Mark: Yeah, let me- let me try
Bob: Hey, hey, hey *while laughing*
Mark: fuckin... fuckin... aackKK
Wade: Will you guys please get in the car? I'm waiting.
Bob: *Laughing*
Mark: get the- FUCKING!
Bob: *laughing*
Mark: Fuck!
Mark: FUCK!
Bob & Wade: *laughing*
Mark: There we go.
Mark: Alright that didn't fucking work.
Bob: uhh- the one that drives
Mark: Wade!
Bob: Oh no, is it-
Mark: hang on a second-
Wade: Uuhhh ughhh
Bob: Hey Wade
Wade: UUHHH UHUH AhHH
Bob: Hey buddy
Wade: UH UH EH EH EH UH
Mark: these are left-hand drive! (one handed LEFT HAND drive? UNSAFE!)
Bob: Oh fuck!
Mark: THIS is the driver's seat!
Wade: *laughs*
Bob: We're just idiots!
Mark & Wade: *laugh*
Bob: God damn it!
Mark: *laughing* I mean it's right hand drive (STILL UNSAFE)
Bob: Yeah, its the opposite of what it's supposed to be
Wade: Woo.....!
Mark: Why are the doors still open
Bob: Man, everybody was just calling us fucking idiots-
Wade: hey Bob-
Bob: For a long time
Mark: So, are we gonna keep in the moment where I said we should
Mark: fucking bail- fucking bail on this game?
Bob: Yes, we should
Wade: Wait- didn't it just ramp into the wall?
Mark: Maybe
Bob: kinda
Wade: ok
Mark: *various car noises*
Wade: Let's do it... do it
Wade & Mark: BOB! bob! BoB BOB!
Mark: Woah-- HEY....!
Wade: *yelling*
Wade: Oh, uh oh. Oh nailed it
Bob: Oh you can E-Brake! A is E-Brake
Bob: ah hell yeah
Bob: *GASP* You can go first person in the car with left bumper
Mark: Nice... this doesn't help
Bob: Nah this doesn't really help at all, does it?
Mark: just makes it really weird
Bob: Jesus christ. *laughs*
Wade: YEAH
Mark: *speaking in accent begins*
guys, i'm about to-
Wade: There's a robber here!
Mark: approach the pig
Mark: I am approaching currently approaching-
Mark: the pig!
Bob: Are you by modern art? or are you not by modern art
Mark: uh, I am right around the corner from you, Bob!
Mark: Approaching the pig!
Bob: I thought so
Mark: III'M..
Mark: approaching the pig. Ah... pig
Mark: Pig does not like company
Bob: Alright, alright, I found the pig
Wade: Wait, wheres the pig? is it near modern art?
Mark: BOB! BOB
Bob: Oohhh
Wade: Bob is this pig past-
Bob: I... killed the pig
Mark: you killed the pig
Bob: He's fine! he's ok, he's ok
Mark: Oh no! The pig is fine
Mark: alright, i'm gonna attempt to grab the pig
3...
Mark: gonna attempt to graaab the pig!
2...
Mark: Just have to graaab the pig!
Bob: Whatcha doin' to that pig there?
1...
Mark: I''m gonna attemp to grab-
Wade & Mark: *yelling* Woah!
Bob: OH MY GOD
Bob: *giggle*
Mark: *continues accent* alright! attempting to grab the pig
Bob & Wade: *laugh*
Mark: I am riding the pig!
Bob: OH MY GOD MARK'S RIDING THE PIG
Mark: I am riding the pig.
Mark: I am wrassling- wrassling this pig
Bob: fuck you, give me the pig
Mark: Ooh, I have no control over this pig.
Mark: Woah!
Bob: hang on, I'm gonna help! i'm gonna help!
Mark: Ok. Please help me control the pig
Bob: Give me that crown, motherfucker
Wade: No, my crown!
Bob: *yells* Oh!
Wade: *yells* Ow!
Mark: *yells* Hey!
Bob: hey-oh
Mark: *resume normal voice* Alright, riding the pig
Bob: Did you gain control over the pig right now?
Mark: Uh, I can semi-control the pig but it's very slidey
Bob: *laughing*
Mark: Ho Woah There we go, got it!
Mark: Nailed it. Okay, I am currently controlling the pig
Bob: Can I get on with you?
Mark: Uh, try
Bob: Ahh, sorry sorry
Mark: Okay...
Bob: I can't
Mark: attempt
Bob: wade, wade, wade, wade..
Wade: I'm leavin'
Bob: I thought you were comin' towards us
Mark: I'm attempting to ramp the pig..
Bob: Oh, I like this.
I like were this is going.
Bob: *laughter*
Bob: *laughing* His back legs are freaking the fuck out
Mark: pig... Piiiggg... come on!
Bob: *laughing*
Mark: come on, pig!
Mark: piiiggy
Bob: hold on there mr. pig
Mark: pig- fucking- pig-
Mark: alright, screw it-
Bob: Oh no no no NO
Wade: *laughing*
Bob: oh my god- no-
All: *yelling*
Mark: I....
Wade: *laughing*
Bob & Wade: *laughing*
Mark: what- the fuck
Bob & Wade: *keep laughing*
Mark: *yells*
Bob: OH god- I ramped the pig
Bob: in the- in the opposite way of that- that phrase
Mark: what are you doin'
Mark: OH *laughing* fuck
All: *laugh*
Mark: I was looking at Wade *laughing*
Bob: *laughing*
Bob: What are you doin'
Mark: what are you doin' Wade
Mark: * in accent* what are you doin' to my pig- no-
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Jesus
Mark: *annoyed noise*
Wade: I think this is a good place to park
Bob: yeah that's good
Mark: *grunting*
Bob & Wade: *laughing*
Bob: Whatcha doin' there, pig man?
Mark: Ahhh y'know
Bob: Ahh you got outta there
Mark: Fuckin.. No!
Mark: OHH- fuck- Ow!
Wade: Ohhh *laughs*
Bob: *laughs* oh yes!
Mark: Woww--
Bob: That's a good place to park
Mark: my poor pig- alright
Mark: well!
Wade: I can't move
Mark: I think we've fully explored this game to it's fullest potential
Wade: Bob- back up really far in your car
Wade: and ram into me as fast as you can
Bob: I wanna just observe what's happening to this pig
Mark: yeah this is good here
Mark: So! that was The Amazing Frog
Mark: we have no idea- [Banging noise from car}
Mark: We have no idea what we're doing or why we did it
Wade: Uh- uh- Oh
Mark: But uh-
Mark: we have no idea even if this is a-
Mark: video that- didn't give anyone a- a migraine
[banging and crashing]
Bob & Wade: *laughing*
Mark: Either way! thank you everybody so much for watching-
Mark: Thank you Bob and Wade for joining me-
Bob & Wade: *keep laughing*
Mark: and giggling at this- and uh
Bob & Wade: *laughing*
Bob: yeah
Mark: Yeah
Mark: So uh- let us know what you thought down in the comments below
Wade: Oh- oh
Mark: Thanks again everybody for watching
Mark: and uh- what are you trying to do?
Bob: expLOOOODDDEE
All: *yell* OH!
Mark: - and as always!
Mark: We'll see you, in the next video
Mark: Buh bye!
[Crazy La Paint Outro Music plays]
Wade: Hey the pig's okay.
Mark: That fucking pig
Bob: *laughing* The pig is walking away
Bob: *laughing*
Wade: *laughing* He's just leaving
Mark: *speaking as pig* I'm fucking out of here